bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono pochi gesto che sto facendo
così non sono più figo se facciamo così
credo volevo essere un po ganzo beh
spero che vi piaccia forte anche perché
oggi facciamo fortunate sono con pietro
buona visione
non ci sei o di un milione tele partita
pietro non entra non c'è non gioca
giochi invito ciccio gamer invito ciccio
gamer ciccio gamers dove mi viene non
viene riunisco io perché non c'è chi
solo unito fi pronto perché sei nero
macy shop a disegni a me va bene amico
mio io ti spiego come si gioca qua
andiamo alle lande letali con ciccio
gamer funziona se funziona con lui
funzione con tempo
segui me seguite tutti quanti me senza
fare i pirla tutti seduti
ok perfetto so che ti aggrada di molto
qualcosa 0 e gigante però mi riguarda la
casa ma sono sottolinea chi si ricorda
si sottolinea dove è vero ma come fa
essere lì che tu sei sempre più basso ok
il bene ma se sei entrato prima tu non
l'hai presa non è colpa tua
morgan per l no no no non è vero ne fa
così stupido forte porca vacca degente
prima lieto davvero summit ha
contaminato nord e facciamo vedere a
ciccio gamer che non siamo capaci solo
grazie a lui e l'ho buttato per terra fa
vige signori number one
vai vai lascia lo lascia parolin che fa
spider man dove di pisa che qua dentro
sento camminare qua
sei andato andato giù abbiamo fatto
sinora non è morto subito e occhio e non
è morto subito
ma quanta gente c'è lo so non capisco
eccole qua davanti a te scrive un po più
caso a occhio non ha più colpi
occhio poi bravo bravo così giochiamo
così si gioca genico pr sono un po più e
chi meno dall'avvio viene adesso andrà a
fan culo
[Musica]
ciao amico amico seguendoli a
servirebbero prova beh sprechiamo
teoricamente vabbè sprechiamo tante
vedente dente gente in fondo 15 eccolo
lì sta fermo sta arrivando lo vedi lo
vedi proprio che ci sia bisogno di soldi
occhio viper so ancora
madonna si fa schifo giuro non l'ho
preso mezza volta
ma quello che non sono riuscito a
capirlo mezza volta con la destra
eccolo qua l'altro aspetto è che sono
anche bravo continua così si gioca così
quel fucile di verde rai a maya che male
lo so dietro ecco l'ordine qua che male
io ho fatto demolito alla famiglia
sparano io andrò via andresti sono
ammesse le brega chissenefrega del ruolo
che a quanto gli ho fatto male tra
l'altro hanno fatto un ponte è bello e
lo stretto di messina collegato con una
cosa qua ok
prendi la lascio qua di prenderla avrà m
1 a casa un baule è una roba che eccola
qua io io io vivo c'è una sega occhio
perché la gente si tira male verso ecco
qua sinistra parco porca vacca l'ho
mancato qualità la casetta
dietro di noi anche occhio
come faccio
come facevo di moto no no no sbucciato
arma e per fare il mio vittima che era
sopra di sparare mi spieghi perché ti
sei buttato nel me eravamo circondati e
la gente no per altro perché tipo io ero
meno questo bellissimo di entrare ma
hanno colpito da massimiliano questi
casi li facciamo succede next game
qualora venga in mente anarchici 321 via
ma con me direttamente in acqua di
debuttare che cadeva in basso mi spiego
sto trick ve lo dico ragazzi anche se lo
sapete già tutti se ti butti prima in
acqua perchè tutti si apre dopo e quindi
20 giu
ma ancora dobbiamo fare le hai visto se
c'è qualcuno per caso ti ho visto c'era
qualcuno c'era qualcuno qualcuno ha
tirato ma mi fai all'istante
grazie
ho detto che vado io grazie perché è una
valle che ti sparano ruspoli esperto ma
c'e la mitraglietta che devo io sono un
fucile a pompa che gli spari e perché
non ha niente da vedere se esco a
ucciderlo però ha ucciso però mancano
info e mezza dal nulla eccolo vedo che
c'è l'amico c'e nemico qua
vorrei quella sinistra per pazienza c'è
una sinistra non altro una pickled porca
vacca non picotti posso fare niente una
fee coppia via via via scherzavo e
giochiamo a un'altra cosa come ora non
c'è un gruppo sempre colpi che faccio
poi qualcosa che faccio e dico non
uccidete che mio amico non lo uccidete
per farlo come facevo un certo cavalli
li uccido e
guarda che non si gioca e pietro guarda
e impara
si gioca così devi capire che si gioca
così erano interesse perché erano
interesse ma come possiedono i tre non
lo so è capito ma che sono intrecciati
giochi in due ma infatti per chi sei
cosa stonata in mano a mano perché la
home in squadre eravamo in squadra siamo
subito
la prima cosa prima di giocare un gioco
del genere è sapere come funziona il
menu cosa non sempre ovvia a quanto vedo
[Musica]
se incarico dietro aperto che sono
cellulare ci sono la grande e letali vai
ma perché devi dirlo mansueta ridargli
allora andiamo nella città subito sacra
prigione perché non siamo noi ci
arriviamo
dai che abbiamo sempre bisogno di carico
non ci andavo la prigione sempre e per
sempre se ogni volta che devono per tre
mesi fa
vediamo messi ha messi in modo da torre
più a est io vado se sei qua non c'è
niente mi come gira dall'altra parte
credo che c'è qualcosa 400 quali lo
sento
yes o c'è uno fuori dove non c'è una
mano eccolo qua sono sopra sopra dove si
è passato tu
una terra quando sapeva
non equa andati dai vai vai in grande
ora queste mio prendi tutti la scherzava
solamente va bene bravissimo onore così
un pò viola è dove non ci arrivo che
files grazie
no non l'ho preso io vacca che ansia ma
sei scemo agente che rompe nord preciso
e ti vedo bene gli ho tolto qualcosa che
tolta decreto si non so cosa proprio
riprende un certo senso mille colpiti
bush non ha capito lo sto sparando lo ri
colpito bravo oggi e sotto sotto sotto
sotto di te dove di pietro pietro pietro
mi piace così pietro giochi sempre così
che succede proviamoci
vai a cagare dove non so via via via
dietro di atene di aria che male dietro
le prime maya che il dolore ea 35 tipo
non so dove
ecco lo saprai le costruzioni via via
via di qua non serve sant'antonio via
che male mi aspetto un ricercato il nome
non cosa vi ha mosso la sua morte sono
un deficiente poco 14 occhi occhi a
qualche arriva qualche arriva qualche
riva dove sono morte lascia mila persone
morte sono davanti ad empoli dove
stupido davanti a te niente loro non ce
la faccio mio 18 per morire in questo
mondo e perché volevo ammirarlo però ha
detto chissà se microcistine ha colpito
mi ha fatto un monza nella madonna paesi
che si chiama borgo bislacco bike
rischiavo date una portata tastiera non
schiacciate lo spazio per un bravissimo
meno siamo partiti da dio no comunque è
un casino borgo bislacco e cioè un
bordello
quindi occhio che moriamo andiamo subito
in una casa tutti e due
con la sinistra se quella questa qua ok
bisogna
qualcuno ha scritto grazie a gente che
va gente che viene qua ma noi
e quando cavalcavia che cambiamo è poco
e non si facevano parlare a tutta la
gente non lo so non so non credo
c'è gente mette in conto su una barca
una revolver
non ho niente
09 quindi ragazzi che sia stata nostra
esperienza su forte ed è finita molto
bene però lei non abbiamo giocato male
però che vi sia piaciuto ma senso che li
frequento mi piace anche la lista cerca
di giustizia sono esistite indici
vediamo passare da ragazzi
[Musica]